all I know is that you've got condoms
and your hooker
what's dumber than arresting people for
prostitution well how about a city that
passes out condoms for plays and then
arrests people who have condoms why you
need these if he ain't turning tricks
cops in New Orleans this gum often treat
the possession of condoms as evidence of
prostitution according to a recent
report from Human Rights Watch rubbers
equals hookers equals jail and where did
the condoms come from well often from
city health workers or various
nonprofits who are trying to stop the
spread of hiv/aids in the place with the
nation's third highest new infection
rate why else you need condoms
the results are sad but predictable
fearful of police harassment plenty of
prostitutes say they are less likely to
use condoms and that could lead to more
infections cops in LA San Francisco and
Washington DC are similarly suspicious
of condoms but hold on a NOPD does not
arrest individuals for carrying condoms
as possession of condoms is not a crime
so says a police department spokesperson
who goes on to admit that carrying
condoms can by law be considered
evidence of prostitution come on
no cops have better things to do despite
a little recent progress New Orleans
murder rate remains one of the highest
in the nation and stands at more than
eight times the national average zero
instead of sniffing out condoms and
busting adults for consensual acts maybe
cops could spend more time hunting down
murderers and catching violent bugs
follow the show on Twitter submit your
nominees for next month and check out
Ali's sons this month's featured
follower Twitter in me are you
twittering me